This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hi, I'm Rob and welcome to 6 Minute English where we talk about an interesting topic
and six items of related vocabulary.
And I'm Neil and today we're talking about wetticket.
What's that, Rob?
I have no idea.
Well, you won't find wetticket in many dictionaries.
It actually means swimming pool etiquette.
W etiquette.
Get it?
etiquette is a set of rules for how to behave in social situations and wetticket is a set of
do's and don'ts to keep things calm in the water.
Do's and don'ts are also rules telling us how to behave.
So things like no running by the pool or no diving in the shallow end.
Am I right?
Yes and no, Rob.
Those are traditional swimming pool rules, but wetticket covers slightly different things.
Okay, well, before we get to those, I have a question for you, Neil.
According to the US Water Quality and Health Council,
how many people admitted to not showering before using the pool?
Is it a 7%, b 17% or c 70%?
Well, I'm going to be optimistic and say 7%, Rob.
Ah, so I take it, you do always take a shower before swimming, Neil.
Correct.
Taking a quick shower is such an easy thing to do and it stops all that horrible sweat and bacteria
getting in the pool water.
I can't understand why some people don't do it.
I can see it's making you quite hot under the collar and that means angry.
Let's listen to swimming specialist Jenny Landruth talking about what a noise her.
I'm very keen on my wetticket.
Is that thing where people get quite cross about, which is do you gain around clockwise or anticlockwise?
Do you overtake or not?
People need a rule.
We need to observe the rules of the pool and I'm very keen on that and most other swimmers
will suffer from lane rage if people are in the wrong lane of the pool and don't know how to
observe the rules of that lane.
Lane rage, you mean if you're a kind of slow swimmer and you dare to go in the fast swimmer?
Well, I hate to say it but it is quite often that gentlemen quite often misjudge their speed
and think they're slightly faster than me.
Ah, the male ego, yeah.
They quite often don't like it if there's a woman swimming faster than them.
So very often they'll go in the slightly faster lane and should be gently encouraged by wetticket
to get into the correct lane.
No, your speed, I don't have speed.
Yeah.
Yes.
That was Jenny Landruth, a swimming specialist talking about the things that annoy her about other
people in the pool.
Yes, Jenny doesn't like it when people are slower than they should be for the fast lane.
Older men like you, Rob.
Neil, how dare you.
Yes, Jenny gets lane rage.
Lane rage, where swimmers get hot under the collar when there's a slow swimmer in the fast lane.
Swimmy lanes are the vertical sections of a swimming pool that are often labeled as fast,
medium and slow.
Do you know your speed, Neil?
Yes, I'm fast.
Ah, are you sure you're not to misjudging your speed?
Do you think you might actually be a medium fast swimmer?
To misjudge means to guess something wrongly.
And our ego is the idea we have of ourselves with regards to how important we feel we are.
And to answer your question, Rob.
No, I'm definitely fast.
Are there other things Swimmers should be aware of in the pool?
Yes.
If somebody taps your foot, it means they want to overtake you.
Ah, overtaking means to pass another person travelling in the same direction
because you are going faster than them.
I hate it when swimmers overtake me.
Really, Neil, is that your male ego talking?
No, not at all.
I just hate getting splashed.
I see.
Well, perhaps now is a good time to move on and hear the answer to today's quiz question.
Remember, I asked how many people admitted to not showering before using the pool?
Is it a 7%, b 17% or c 70%.
I said 7% and I hope I'm right.
Well, I'm afraid your wrong, Neil.
It's actually 10 times that amount.
It's 70%.
Ugh.
The 2012 US report from Water Quality and Health Council
found that around 70% of people do not shower before taking a swim in the pool,
adding to the number of germs in the water.
Perhaps swimming pools should start finding people who don't take a shower.
That might make a difference.
Now, let's go over the words we learned today.
Yes, the first one is Doos and Don'ts,
which are rules telling us how to behave in a particular situation.
For example, what are the Doos and Don'ts of meeting the queen?
Good question.
Is the correct etiquette to call her your highness or ma'am?
Are there certain subjects you shouldn't talk about?
Do you shake a hand or curtsy?
These are things you need to know or else the queen might get hot under the collar.
That's our next word and it means angry.
Both politicians got hot under the collar and insulted each other.
Okay, number three is lanes,
which are the vertical sections of a swimming pool that are often labeled as fast,
medium and slow.
Our British Olympic gold medalist is swimming in lane one.
Our next word is misjudge, which means to guess something wrongly.
For example, I'm sorry I misjudged you, Rob.
Please forgive me.
Oh, all right, then Neil.
But don't misjudge me again, okay?
Next up is ego, which is our sense of how important we are.
Losing the race was a huge blow to her ego.
And our final word is overtake, which means to pass another person traveling in the same
direction because you are going faster than them.
I don't enjoy overtaking big lorries on the motorway.
Neither do I, Neil.
Now, one of the dos and don'ts of this show is not talking for more than six minutes.
So it's time to say goodbye.
But please visit our Twitter, Facebook and YouTube pages and tell us what makes you hot under the
collar.
And remember, you can explore our website, BBCLearningEnglish.com,
where you'll find guides to grammar, exercises, videos and articles to read,
and improve your English.
Bye-bye, goodbye.